[Music]
so we have a huge nerf gun Arsenal we're
gonna show you guys the best nerf guns
we're gonna show you guys the worst nerf
guns we're gonna show you guys our
special nerf guns we got a lot let's
jump in I keep coming back to one never
found over the years this one right here
it's called like the strife and that's
because it's really small you can use it
like as a right foal you can put the
stock on it but also you can use it as a
pistol this one is battery-powered
super super easy to mod that's why it's
my favorite what is the best nerf gun in
general that's an easy answer it's this
gun this is by far the best nerf gun
there has ever made the second best nerf
gun is a hammer shot these guns seem
very similar but they have their own
unique features
this gun is super accurate a single shot
it's kind of loud this gun however you
can pump with one hand being able to do
that
mix all their personal world you can do
a wheel and be pumping your guns and
shooting them at the same time also this
is by far the best stealth nerf gun
Parishad will never let you down I don't
know what this was cold it's one of
those zombie strike like two shot ones
this is like the best concealed nerf
weapon you can also fan the hammer I
mean they were like the most reliable
for actually hitting people in games for
you just like compare that's like
something like this which has a motor in
it way less stealthy no SIL runners up
here is the sling fire which is a
magazine-fed can also like beautiful
like terminator thing which is fun this
is just super reliable and it shoots
straight and it holds a lot of rounds
you know I think a good replacement for
that orange nerf gun of yours Sam this
is basically the same no you're right Oh
way more stylish yeah they literally
just reskin the same nerf gun with her
you know there's sound like Darryl how
do you have so much style I just don't
have it did you go over this one these
little pea shooters are actually really
accurate and they shoot really far check
this out things my classic go to because
it's reliable it's got six shots which
is one more than the hammer shot shoots
pretty dang pretty dang far as well can
you load it with one hand you can't load
it with one hand that's the only problem
but who's really using two guns anyway
[Music]
this is my honorable mention because
this is the gun I've had the highest
hopes and dreams for the sledgefire
you open up the chamber here and you
actually have these little capsules
these little clips that have three darts
and you load it like that and it's so
cool and shoots three at a time and it's
pretty cool right it's just the problem
is that it's really slow to load and
also you can only hold like three of
these little clips here at the same time
conceptually this is like the coolest
most stylish one to have rough cut worst
gun on the market free three darts came
out all the two are supposed to come out
and now see how this one's part way out
you won't even shoot now dude gross yeah
what's the next one all ready gun do
this
see see ball action dude dude okay
here's another piece broke I know it's a
sound you know what that sound is that's
the sound of a breaking nerf gun after
200 rounds your best bet is simplicity
now this guns pretty sweet actually it's
giant it's mega it's got the most
satisfying bolt action in the world and
when it shoots the bolt inside releases
[Music]
[Applause]
so this one's you can actually just pump
it like you would like a squirt gun
whereas all these other ones you only
have a fixed amount of air that you can
put into the chamber or is this one you
just keep pumping until I can't go any
more
dude you pumped it too much no this one
has like an insane rate of fire
this one's reminded full-auto nerf gun
no one's ever seen it work because i've
never used it in a video because it's
too unfair how can you forget the mega
this is the mega it's like one of the
first mega dart launchers looking at it
only holds three shots super reliable
[Music]
getting it in the eye with this would
hurt a lot what Turner
[Applause]
so the rules of nerve is that if you say
that you hit somebody they must call
themselves out so it keeps everybody
honorable keeps the games level-headed I
[Applause]
accidently found the hammer in wonder
yeah I got a weird note on my doorstep
last night and it's on your door yeah
they know where I live
this right here yeah give it an idea
that this would be a couple guesses
[Music]
you know anything about this you seen
this before I'm nursing that in my life
before Sun says that you're gonna
forcibly shave him with malice
intentionally no no that's assault right
look man I'm a beard guy you know that
you know that if I had anyone threatened
what I got going on right here mm-hmm
I'd say that's a score that would need
settling for sure you know and I want to
do that to you as a beard guy I've seen
this a couple times it never ends well
the problem is for me no one will give
me any information and I'm afraid not
only is it cutting into productivity but
something's gonna break out at the
office I gotta find a way to stop this